[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et cette semaine nous
accueillons Arthur Delaporte bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes députés
socialiste du Calvados vous avez été élu
en juin dernier il y a beaucoup
d'actualités pour vous et oui c'était la
dernière semaine des travaux
parlementaires avant la trêve hivernale
et depuis le mois de juillet le
gouvernement d'Elizabeth borne a fait
voter 12 textes en s'appuyant parfois
sur les députés de droite mais aussi sur
le Sénat on fera le bilan de cette
session et puis à la rentrée de janvier
un dossier explosif attendra les députés
les sénateurs celui des retraites
Emmanuel Macron présente le 10 janvier
les grandes lignes de sa réforme des
retraites et cette semaine la première
ministre a consulté les groupes
parlementaires et puis l'autre texte
chaud du début d'année 2023 ce sera le
projet de loi sur l'immigration qui
prévoit notamment de régulariser les
travailleurs sans papiers avant la
présentation du texte et bien à les
sénateurs ont exprimé leur position lors
d'un débat ce mardi
les travaux parlementaires vont donc
être suspendus l'occasion pour nous de
faire un petit bilan depuis l'élection
de la nouvelle Assemblée 12 textes ont
été votés par le Parlement et ce malgré
l'absence nette de majorité l'exécutif a
donc réussi à trouver des alliés pour
faire adopter certaines de ces réformes
séances rétro avec Elsa mandagaba
si le marathon budgétaire a donné lieu à
une succession de 49,3 et de motions de
censure pas de paralysie au Parlement
depuis juillet 12 textes ont été adoptés
pour 210 contre 140 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté pour 197 contre 60
est nationale a adopté pour cela
plusieurs stratégies comptez sur le
Sénat jugez plus constructif et moins
politique qu'une assemblée en ébullition
le gouvernement a réservé à la Chambre
haute la primeur de l'examen de certains
textes il paraît aussi sur la bonne
volonté des sénateurs de droite
notamment lors des commissions mixtes
paritaires ces réunions pour trouver un
accord entre les deux chambres le
gouvernement a aussi cherché à
convaincre des groupes d'opposition à
l'Assemblée jusqu'à présent surtout la
droite comme pour la réforme de
l'assurance chômage ou encore la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur la droite en renfort de la
majorité mais sur les énergies
renouvelables c'est bien sur les voies
de la gauche que contre l'exécutif autre
méthode nouvelle dans la majorité se
montrer ouverte sur des textes d'autres
groupes politiques comme la proposition
de loi constitutionnalisant le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
portée par les insoumis le texte que
nous nous apprêtons à voter et je
l'espère avec la plus large majorité
possible aujourd'hui ce texte là devient
le texte de notre assemblée devient le
texte qui doit toutes et tous nous
réunir une assemblée qui entre 49,3
émotions de censure avancent c'est
l'image que veut mettre en avant le
gouvernement avec une nuance toutefois
pour ne pas être mise en minorité la
majorité a dû elle aussi faire de
l'obstruction comme sur la réintégration
des soignants non vaccinés par ailleurs
ce sont deux textes particulièrement
sensibles qui attendent le gouvernement
et les parlementaires à la rentrée 2023
les retraites et l'immigration
[Musique]
Arthur de la porte finalement sans
majorité absolue 12 textes ont été votés
cela montre que l'exécutif n'est pas si
affaibli que ça ça montre surtout qu'il
a réussi à se trouver un allié de
circonstance qui a la droite et donc sur
chacun des textes ou presque il a pu
compter sur l'appui des députés LR qui
n'ont pas spécialement envie d'être vu
comme des obstructeurs mais qui se
retrouvent de fait finalement complice
ou en tout cas soutien du gouvernement
qui en échange leur donne parfois
quelques gages c'est la force d'appoint
de la majorité pour vous c'est une
évidence et je pense que la plupart des
collègues LR assument c'est à dire
qu'ils sont dans une logique où ils sont
les supplétifs d'une majorité qui est
minoritaire et qui a donc besoin d'aller
chercher des soutiens et ce qui conduit
par ailleurs à des textes qui sont
toujours plus à droite et le
gouvernement qui s'appuie également sur
la majorité de droits de sénatoriales
pour trouver des compromis sur certains
textes comme le projet loi d'orientation
et de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur la réforme de l'assurance
chômage donc finalement ce que vous
dites c'est que une alliance entre le
gouvernement et la droite qui ne dit pas
son nom en tout cas j'ai été pour ma
part dans la commission mixte paritaire
donc qui a fabriqué le texte actuel de
l'assurance chômage et c'est la député
il y avait des députés et des sénateurs
et où LR dominant au Sénat était
majoritaire et en marche à l'Assemblée
et j'avais l'impression d'assister à un
échange de bonne camarades et surtout de
voir le texte au fur et à mesure se
dégrader en tout cas les droits des
chômeurs être réduits progressivement
par à la fois les à-coups portés par la
philosophie de cette réforme qui
constitue c'est consistait à taper
toujours plus sur les chômeurs et aussi
avec LR qui a introduit par exemple une
présomption de démission d'abandon de
poste et donc voilà des choses tout à
fait inédites dans le droit qui à mon
avis seront contestés aussi devant les
tribunaux parce qu'elles sont assez
choquantes mais voilà ça c'est l'apport
de LR c'est d'avoir réussi à durcir des
textes qui étaient déjà antisociaux bon
écoutez on ne peut que le constater
alors Elizabeth borne a utilisé pas
moins de 10 fois l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution pour faire passer en force
les budgets et notamment une baisse
d'impôts de 8 milliards d'euros sur les
entreprises sans l'accord du Parlement
vous dites quoi je vais pas me féliciter
cette situation où des députés n'ont pas
été consultés sur des dépenses
fondamentales pour l'équilibre de la
nation je veux dire on avait un certain
nombre de positions à défendre on aurait
bien aimé parler du budget de
l'éducation de la police ou encore du
budget général de l'État vous évoquez
ici 8 milliards d'euros qu'on était
supprimés comme ça cet historique c'est
ce que a rappelé d'ailleurs ma collègue
Valérie rabot lorsqu'elle a pris la
parole il y a une semaine de cela on a
un budget d'État qui est de 300
milliards vous vous rendez compte vous
avez quasiment 2% du budget de l'État
qui est supprimé sans vote enfin sans
débat sans que les parlementaires les
députés en l'occurrence aient pu
échanger sur ce point c'est choquant
j'espère que les Français et les
Français sont aussi choqués et ça révèle
autre chose ça révèle que ce
gouvernement qui disait vouloir
construire une nouvelle méthode fondée
sur le compromis le consensus et surtout
un gouvernement qui est assez dirigiste
et qui n'écoute pas et ne cherche même
pas à faire vivre le débat dans le
Parlement qui te met à le mettre un peu
plus tard ce qui est en 3 puisque bon on
peut toujours comprendre qu'ils n'ont
pas de majorité mais même pas c'est au
début il y a même eu un soir assez
singulier où on venait de débattre d'une
motion de censure sur le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
zéro minute 0 seconde après la fin de ce
débat sur la motion de censure nouveau
49-3 ce qui fait que la quatrième partie
du projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale a été réputé adopté
sans même qu'on ait pu en discuter
Arthur de la porte l'affaire adrien
catenens a également marqué ce début de
session parlementaire et à fragiliser
l'alliance de la Nupe à gauche le député
insoumis qui a reconnu on le rappelle
avoir giflé sa femme a été condamné à 4
mois de prison avec sursis il a été
suspendu temporairement de son groupe la
France insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale
mais il l'a dit il souhaite revenir en
janvier dans l'hémicycle en tant que
député non inscrit vous comprenez son
choix de revenir à l'Assemblée je le
comprends pas et par ailleurs je trouve
que les mots qu'il a employés ça
communication cette semaine et était
manip particulièrement mal à l'aise
quand vous a choqué ce déballage je peux
vous dire que non seulement j'ai été
choqué mais aussi je me suis dit qu'il
n'avait manifestement pas compris ce qui
s'était passé dans son cas personnel et
ce qui se passait plus largement en
France aujourd'hui quand on est le
responsable quand on était le
responsable d'un parti politique la
France insoumise qui se revendique
féministe et qui l'est quand on est dans
un accord laupes avec des parties comme
le Parti socialiste qui exigent de leur
responsabilité une exemplarité quand on
reconnaît avoir frappé sa femme quand on
est condamné à une peine de prison une
peine de prison avec sursis certes mais
c'est une peine
et qu'on revient en disant circuler
c'est bon j'ai compris mais en même
temps je suis pas vraiment coupable mais
en même temps voilà vous comprenez la
des circonstances ce n'est pas le sujet
le sujet il est certes judiciaire il a
eu sa peine mais il est aussi politique
éthique et morale et donc là j'ai trouvé
que en effet le prime time d'Adrien
catenin cette semaine était assez
indécent et donc voilà moi je suis assez
mal à l'aise sur cette situation et
c'est pour ça que je me réjouis d'une
part de la position qui a été cette
position de la France insoumise même si
elle aurait pu être plus dure et je
l'aurais souhaité plus dur mais d'une
exclusion elle est temporaire mais je
pense qu'on y reviendra moi j'aurais
souhaité une exclusion définitive après
voilà on en rediscutera ce qui est
certain c'est que je suis assez mal à
l'aise sur cette situation et on verra
ce qui se passe en attendant on va
parler du grand sujet de cette rentrée
2023 Arthur de la porte ce sera
évidemment celui des retraites Emmanuel
Macron présentera les contours de sa
réforme en janvier le 10 janvier en
attendant Elisabeth borne consulte à
tout va alors qui pense quoi et que du
gouvernement écoutez ce florilège de
réactions assemblées par Cécile even
quel que soit nos différences pour
sauver notre système de retraite par
répartition nous restons ouverts aux
propositions nous restons déterminés à
dialoguer à construire et agir je vous
remercie
j'ai présenté
majorité sénatoriale va depuis plusieurs
années
qui est une réforme qui est très
équilibrée qui est je crois juste et qui
est un mélange de report de l'âge légal
pas à 65 ans à 64 ans progressivement et
ajouter à une accélération de la réforme
Touraine mais pas à 45 ans à 43 ans une
réforme c'est quand on améliore les
conditions de vie des gens ici il s'agit
d'une contre-réforme imposée par le
gouvernement et qui vise à nous faire
travailler plus longtemps jusqu'à 64 ou
65 ans et d'ailleurs le gouvernement
impose un débat sur un tout petit point
ça va creuser les inégalités et ça va
faire que de plus en plus de personnes
ne vont pas pouvoir profiter des
meilleurs années de la retraite c'est
tout simplement inadmissible et en
particulier dans un contexte de crise
multiple alors Elisabeth band se dit
ouverte aux propositions elle l'a dit
devant la représentation nationale lors
des questions d'actualité est-ce que
vous au Parti socialiste vous êtes
d'accord prêt à négocier à faire des
propositions en fait ce que j'aime bien
avec Elisabeth borne c'est que cette
nouvelle méthode c'est une forme
d'hypocrisie permanente parce que on
sait très bien que elle est ouverte et
en même temps elle refuse de négocier
sur le report de l'âge légal elle est
ouverte et en même temps elle nous dit
je considère que le régime des retraites
doit être réformé ce qui n'est pas une
nécessité donc finalement cette
ouverture c'est une ouverture de façade
derrière c'est un gouvernement qui font
cette baisser et droit dans le mur parce
que à la fin il y a des risques qui sont
économiques sur cette réforme elle ne
mesure pas ou en tout cas elle n'en
parle pas il y a des risques sociaux et
ça non plus c'est jamais évoqué et on ne
peut jamais en discuter et donc moi je
considère que on a un gouvernement qui
fait la sourde oreille à gauche
notamment et qui cherchent à aller LR à
sa politique mais malheureusement sur
les retraites j'ai l'impression que ça
ne sera pas aussi simple que sur le
reste parce que les députés LR ont l'air
d'être aussi sensible à l'injustice
profonde qui est portée dans cette
réforme en tout cas au moins une partie
d'entre eux cette réforme des retraites
est-ce que ça va être finalement le
grand combat de la gauche et des
syndicats en 2023 alors ce qui est sûr
c'est que nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés et vous projetiez à l'instant
des images d'une conférence de presse
qui s'est tenue mercredi dernier avec
l'ensemble des groupes politiques de la
gauche de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat c'est important parce que ça
montre notre unité collective face à
toute tout recule du départ de l'âge
légal à la retraite ça montre aussi
notre mobilisation aux côtés des
syndicats ce qu'on a dit je dis dernier
c'était donnez-nous votre date nous
serons avec vous dans la rue nous sommes
à vos côtés pour faire que la
mobilisation sociale face au refus qui
est majoritaire chez les Français et les
Français de cette réforme soit la plus
importante possible alors vous aviez dit
que les comptes n'étaient pas si en
déficit que ça vous avez lu comme tout
le monde le rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites
le gouvernement dit qu'il y a quand même
une urgence à réformer le système des
retraites vous que proposez-vous pour
redresser les comptes qui sont quand
même dans le rouge alors c'est pas vrai
cette année les comptes sont
excédentaires c'est 900 millions d'euros
vous comptez les chiffres du corps ça
c'est les chiffres généraux c'est
excédentaire le déficit du régime des
retraites il est à horizon 2027 sauf que
que disent les spécialistes
ne réforme pas un régime parce qu'il est
déficitaire dans cinq ans les retraites
c'est pour toute une vie et même plus
c'est à dire qu'il faut réformer à
horizon 2050 ou 2070 et qu'est-ce qu'on
voit à cet horizon c'est que finalement
ça s'équilibre peu ou proue et que on
est sur des déficits qui s'y peuvent
exister sont assez léger on est même en
2027 entre 0,8 et 1 % de nécessité
de réformer il y a pas de nécessité
immédiate et si on se dit qu'il faut
parce que on a les effets d'augmentation
des dépenses qui sont liées notamment à
la génération des baby-boomers on peut
avoir ponctuellement un besoin de
financement mais alors il y a pas
absolument besoin de repousser l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite c'est 12
milliards d'euros qu'il faut trouver 12
milliards vous évoquiez à l'instant une
suppression d'un impôt à 8 milliards
d'euros donc d'un côté
d'un côté on supprime un impôt sur les
entreprises de 8 milliards d'euros et de
l'autre on fait travailler les Français
deux ou trois ans de plus vous rendez
compte de l'injustice total enfin je
veux dire on n'a pas besoin aujourd'hui
chercher de l'argent sur la vie des
Françaises et des Français parce que ce
qui se passe quand on repousse l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite c'est
qu'on renforce les inégalités parce
qu'on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
entre les 5% les plus pauvres et les 5%
les plus riches il y a 13 ans de
différence d'espérance de vie et que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé des
travailleurs les plus pauvres
aujourd'hui c'est à peine quelques
années après l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite donc ce qu'on veut c'est
simplement supprimer le droit à la
retraite des plus pauvres et bien ça on
ne peut pas l'accepter et ça sera une
ligne rouge c'est une ligne rouge
évidemment c'est inacceptable et nous
serons mobilisés pour cela parce que on
l'a vu 12 milliards d'euros enfin 12
milliards d'euros 8 milliards d'euros
par rapport au budget total des
retraites Arthur c'est pas grand chose
vous parliez de l'unité de la nupaisse
de l'alliance des parlementaires de
gauche contre cette réforme des
retraites mais quand on regarde vos
propositions par exemple est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec la France insoumise
qui veut revenir à la retraite à 60 ans
ça la retraite à 60 ans dans le
programme que nous avons sur lequel je
me suis engagé c'est un objectif c'est
un horizon d'accord
la question principale dans les mois qui
viennent c'est le front commun qui
englobe tous les syndicats tout tous les
forces politiques nous refusons le
report de l'âge légal ça sera le seul et
unique moderne dans les mois qui
viennent c'est assez clair je pense donc
on peut avoir aussi des sujets
d'amélioration il faut mieux prendre en
compte la pénibilité
vous vous lirez précisément nous
expliquons qu'il faut une prise en
compte notamment pour celles et ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt que les
carrières longues soient mieux reconnues
que la pénibilité soit mieux reconnue
l'enjeu il est là il est là et surtout
je le redis dans notre opposition à
cette réforme des plus injustes mais moi
je suis malade quand je pense à ce que
nous allons devoir examiner dans
quelques mois et ce contre quoi nous
allons nous battre alors l'autre texte
sensible de ce début d'année 2023 ce
sera le projet de loi immigration il
prévoit d'accélérer de facilité les
expulsions notamment aux étrangers
délinquants et en même temps de
régulariser les travailleurs sans
papiers dans les métiers en tension
alors avant la présentation du texte les
sénateurs ont donné cette semaine leur
avis dans l'hémicycle lors d'un débat
Jonathan Dupriez
[Musique]
les sénateurs ont salué la méthode pour
débattre avec eux de la future loi sur
l'immigration plusieurs ministres de
premier plan ont été dépêchés dans
l'hémicycle de la chambre haute à
commencer par Elisabeth borne la
première ministre sait le sujet sensible
mais affirme d'ores et déjà s'inspirer
des travaux du Sénat pour élaborer son
texte je sais en introduisant ce au
Sénat que nous partons sur des
fondements solides
la Haute Assemblée a toujours eu à coeur
de porter des débats d'idées et de
chercher des solutions communes
vous avez aussi je le sais et j'y
reviendrai travailler sur la question
migratoire sur ces implications et sur
les grands chantiers à mener sur le fond
le gouvernement dit vouloir une réforme
alliant efficacité humanité et fermeté
principale mesure qui pourrait figurer
dans le projet de loi accélérer les
procédures de demande d'asile pour les
faire passer d'un an à 6 mois mais aussi
accélérer les expulsions d'étrangers
menaçant l'ordre public le gouvernement
voudrait aussi faciliter l'application
des OQTF les obligations de quitter le
territoire leur taux d'application est
très faible aujourd'hui un problème
souligné par le président de la
commission des Lois du Sénat le taux
d'exécution des eqtf se situe selon les
chiffres transmis par le ministère un
niveau famélique de 6,9% au premier
semestre 2022 on peut toujours discuter
la pertinence de ce taux mais nous ne
pouvons pas nous ne pouvons que
constater un indicateur constant nous
exécutionons encore 22% de nos hôpitaux
en 2012 trois fois plus qu'aujourd'hui
sans surprise socialiste deuxième force
politique du Sénat reste très opposée
aux futurs projets de loi seul point
salué par leur chef de fil sur
l'immigration Jean-Yves Leconte la
volonté du gouvernement de créer des
titres de séjour métiers en tension pour
faciliter le recrutement de travailleurs
immigrés et même qu'il faudrait aller à
moins sens beaucoup plus loin on a vu
que quand on donne tout de suite droit
au travail à des personnes qui sont
protégées par la France on l'a vu avec
les Ukrainiens ça marche moi j'ai la
conviction que travailler à l'autonomie
des personnes qui arrivent dès qu'elles
arrivent c'est nécessaire même si
apprendre à leur dire non désolé vous
n'avez pas la protection repoussez à
plusieurs reprises depuis l'été le futur
projet de loi immigration arrivera au
Sénat en mars 2023 la chambre haute
examinera ce texte en premier avant
l'Assemblée nationale Arthur de la porte
qu'on se texte viendra l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que les députés
socialistes pourraient voter NON NON
quand on a eu le débat il y a à peu près
deux semaines sur ce sujet là Gérald
Darmanin a commencé en citant Bainville
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas c'est
un royaliste nationaliste antisémite et
il commence le texte sans prendre aucune
distance par rapport aux propos de
l'auteur moi j'ai été profondément
choqué mais j'ai aussi été finalement
rassuré dans mon opposition parce que
cette réforme qui se dit ferme et
humaine à la fois vous savez cet élément
de langage qu'on entend depuis 1980 il y
a eu 29 lois différentes une loi toutes
les deux ans à peu près sur
l'immigration donc finalement on a
toujours dit on est l'humanité et la
fermeté mais là moi je ne vois que la
fermeté et l'inhumanité quand on regarde
ce qui se passe la manière dont sont
aujourd'hui traités des étrangers sans
papier par Gérald Darmanin qui a produit
une circulaire
ignoble en novembre dernier qui
considère les personnes sous occupé
comme des délinquants mais
soyons raisonnables vous savez
aujourd'hui les personnes sous au qtf et
on pourra en reparler ce ne sont pas
tous et c'est une minorité qui est
délinquant de droit pénal alors Gérald
dahmana dit qu'il veut mieux expulser
mais aussi mieux intégrer selon sa
formule il y a notamment l'idée de créer
un titre de séjour pour les métiers dit
en tension notamment la restauration
l'hôtellerie le bâtiment pour vous
est-ce que ça pourrait être une bonne
idée vous savez premièrement il y a pas
besoin d'une noix pour cela Manuel Valls
en 2012 quand il est arrivé enfin quand
les socialistes sont arrivés au
gouvernement a fait une circulaire qui
permettait justement la régularisation
pour des motifs économiques donc
finalement rien de nouveau sous le
soleil on est en train ici d'aller dans
une mesure qui est de bon sens quand je
suis aujourd'hui en circonscription j'ai
des personnes qui viennent à ma
permanence des étrangers qui sont
aujourd'hui sous au qtf donc obligations
quitter le territoire et devoir être
expulsé mais qui pour certains
travaillent dans les CHU qui pour
d'autres sont aident à domicile qui pour
d'autres travaillent dans le bâtiment ou
dans la restauration et donc qui sont
évidemment
utile à notre pays qui trouve en France
un cadre de vie plus accueillant souvent
que dans leur propre pays mais je ne
vois pas pour moi le problème sur ce
point là par contre il ne faut pas que
cela soit utilisé pour faire des
étrangers une main d'oeuvre corvéable à
merci mais c'est toujours mieux d'avoir
des étrangers qui sont en situation
régulière qui sont avec des contrats de
travail qui bénéficient du SMIC que
d'avoir du travail au noir et de
l'exploitation et de l'exploitation
notamment de la misère humaine c'est
inacceptable donc ça c'est une mesure
qui va dans le bon sens mais il y avait
pas besoin d'une loi pour ça et surtout
il y avait déjà un cadre juridique qui
le permettait vous parliez des occultés
F des obligations de quitter le
territoire français et ce qu'il n'y a
pas quand même un problème quand et bien
seulement 10% de ces décisions
d'expulsion sont effectivement
appliquées au final vous savez il faut
dire 10% de quoi déjà le nombre de ou
qtf a été augmenté de 50% c'est trois ou
quatre dernières années pourquoi parce
que Gérald Darmanin notamment et Gérard
Collomb auparavant ont eu
des consignes données au préfet en leur
disant votre expulsé vous n'étudiez plus
vraiment les dossiers dans le détail et
par ailleurs il y a des changements dans
la procédure avec la dématérialisation
ce qui fait que on ne voit plus
l'étranger comme un être en chair et en
eau c'est plus quelqu'un qui vient dans
un bureau à la préfecture mais c'est un
dossier des matérialisé et par
conséquent on a augmenté le nombre de
qtf de ce point de vue là et puis par
ailleurs il y a des pays avec lesquels
on a un certain nombre de contentieux
diplomatiques qui refusent de donner
finalement l'autorisation aux personnes
sous-oculaires de revenir par exemple en
Algérie et ça ça a été un sujet ces
derniers mois donc vous voyez c'est pour
ça qu'on a un faible taux d'exécution
notamment est-ce que vous pensez sur ce
texte qui risque d'être durci
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il le
gouvernement peut utiliser le 49-3 pour
faire passer en force
si le gouvernement décide de griller un
49-3 sur un texte qui n'a aucune utilité
qui n'apporte rien à la situation des
Françaises et des Français qui se
contentent de faire de la com sur un
enjeu je trouve pour moi scandaleux je
vous ai évoqué tout à l'heure Bainville
nationaliste et antisémites cité parmi
de l'Intérieur bon ben voilà on a ici en
effet un véritable problème de fond
parce que moi si j'étais gouvernant je
ne choisissais pas d'utiliser la seule
cartouche que j'ai pour faire passer un
texte sur une telle réforme Arthur de la
porte on va finir cette émission en
regardant l'agenda du Parlement dans ce
début d'année 203
[Musique]
et pour le mois de janvier et bien il y
aura effectivement la présentation de la
réforme des retraites le 10 janvier
Emmanuel Macron dévoilera les grandes
lignes de cette réforme le texte sera
présenté en Conseil des ministres à la
fin du mois de janvier un mois qui sera
également marqué par le début de
l'examen du projet loi censé accélérer à
la construction de réacteurs nucléaires
et puis au mois de février Alexandre le
Sénat débutera l'examen du projet de loi
immigration qui sera débattue en mars à
l'Assemblée et puis une proposition de
loi pour introduire dans la Constitution
le droit à l'IVG elle a été votée à
l'unanimité à l'Assemblée nationale et
bien le texte sera examiné par le Sénat
il a été votée en tout cas largement à
l'Assemblée nationale la majorité de
droite est plutôt hostile Arthur doit
Laborde pour finir une question sur ce
projet de loi qui est censé accélérer la
construction de réacteurs nucléaires on
le voit en cette période de grand froid
on manque d'énergie électrique est-ce
que c'est pas aussi la faute des
socialistes qui ont pris la décision et
des écologistes qui ont pris la décision
de fermer la centrale de Fessenheim vous
savez c'est pas parce qu'on a fermé
Fessenheim aujourd'hui qu'on est dans
une situation de pénurie d'énergie on
est dans cette situation parce qu'on a
une partie du parc nucléaire qui est à
l'arrêt les réacteurs sont maintenant
c'est un peu plus ou moins la moitié
même si ça repart progressivement et
puis aussi parce que on a une forme de
transition avec une augmentation de la
demande d'électricité avec des nouveaux
des nouvelles phénomènes de consommation
électrique
générale du pays et puis enfin je
voudrais vous dire qu'on avait cette
semaine à l'Assemblée un texte sur les
énergies renouvelables et que l'enjeu
c'est évidemment de développer les
panneaux solaires le photovoltaïque
l'éolien pour enfin électrifier et
surtout faire de notre énergie énergie
bas carbone et peu dangereuse la
question du nucléaire c'est une énergie
de transition mais nous pensons qu'il
faut en sortir et ça c'est à horizon
environ 2050 donc voilà ça c'est notre
position très vite on termine cette
émission avec un mot vous allez faire
l'ordre du jour député socialiste le 9
février en séance publique vous déposez
contexte ou Arthur de la porte sur les
influenceurs en deux mots c'est quoi en
deux mots les influenceurs vous savez
c'est ceux qui font de la pub sur les
réseaux sociaux ils sont fait une
notoriété avec la télé-réalité et il
l'utilise pour vendre pour certains des
pilules miracles contre le cancer pour
d'autres ils font de la pub pour des
paris sportifs pour d'autres de la
chirurgie esthétique bref ça ne peut
plus durer il faut mettre un peu d'ordre
là dedans parce que les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas la loi de la jungle donc moi
ce que je propose c'est d'interdire un
certain nombre de publicités et puis
aussi de dire quand c'est de la pub
parce que le plus souvent ils se font
payer ou ils ont des avantages en nature
mais ils le disent pas donc marquons sur
les postes Instagram ceci est de la
publicité j'ai été payé pour ça votre
texte en séance merci Arthur de la porte
et c'est la fin de ce dernier numéro de
Parlement hebdo pour l'année 2022 merci
beaucoup Arthur de la porte d'y avoir
participé merci à tous de l'avoir suivi
et très bonne fête de fin d'année
[Musique]